i don't poop every day like a lot of  people i poop probably three times a  week  what i poop about three times a day  oh my god i'm not even making that up  you're getting after it huh what are you  a machine gun  yeah man my toilet hates me  my toilet's like you again you do work i  [ __ ] it up bro  that's crazy i don't like doing that i  like to let it get let it get compact  and let it [ __ ] and then you actually  are  serving legitimate poop i'm not out here  just [ __ ] you know uh  soft serving every afternoon like some  [ __ ] little wait so you're  building it you only have to [ __ ] for  about 15 minutes then it goes away dude  i don't give in to the first sign of  pressure  he like he likes he likes to challenge  himself okay i don't  so it's a game for you it's a mental  game for theo i find that the whole  thing works better for my body it's my  my body knows it doesn't have the easy  way out all the time yeah show that show  that [ __ ] who's boss am i right